You probably had the
most disgusting moment
in the history of
"Alone" because things
were getting so dire you
decided to eat leeches.
[suspenseful piano music]
Oh, what the heck.
Let's get these all
four, all at once.
I'm still deciding if I'm
going to throw up or not.
[laughs]
[sarcastic laughing]
Gross.
Ew, gross.
Yuck.
- Did you just throw up?
- I did not.
Oh, come on.
Really?
I did not throw up.
What did they taste like?
A tainted leather green
bean is what they taste
like, really chewy.
But it's protein, right?
- Yeah.
There's something in
there that is good for me.
I'd probably go after
more, to tell you the truth
and stockpile my leeches.
It's not every day
you get to take part
in organic, local,
free range leech.
You can't buy that at the store.
I think we've invented
a whole new fad.